aus meiner sicht zunächst einmal finde
es auch sehr enttäuschend dass in den
ländern in den vor 120 jahren die emo
theologie große erfolge feierte in
frankreich und in deutschland pasteur
und koch zu nennen
dass gerade in den ländern dass mit dem
impfen jetzt so schleppend läuft und
offenbar zu wenig impfstoff im vorfeld
reserviert worden ist so dass die firmen
sozusagen ihre produktionskapazitäten
nicht entsprechend ausgebaut haben so
dass man schon mit dem ersten und
schnellsten anbieter die risikopatienten
zumindest in europa durch impfen kann
und und ich weiß nicht wer dafür
verantwortlich ist vielleicht das ist
auch jetzt nicht an der zeit der
schuldzuweisungen zu machen
auf jeden fall wäre es aus meiner sicht
extrem wichtig dass jetzt gegengesteuert
wird und dass jetzt tatsächlich man
heute weiß man ja welche wettbewerber
aussichtsreich sind und welches nicht
schaffen werden nahe zukunft zugelassen
zu werden und mit denen die zugelassen
sind oder in naher zukunft zugelassen
werden und sollte man versuchen
nachzusteuern und möglichst viele
impfdosen zu reservieren so dass
zumindestens die risikogruppen in der
bevölkerung in deutschland rund die
hälfte der bevölkerung durchgeimpft
werden kann
radbruch um sozusagen es besser zu
machen jetzt sondern der zukunft muss
man ja erst mal verstehen was da jetzt
wirklich schief gelaufen ist in der
vergangenheit und den wir jetzt noch mal
so ein bisschen zurückschauen ist es ja
so dass die verteidigungslinie der
regierung des bundesgesundheitsministers
seit tagen seit wochen ist wir haben
eben am anfang auf viele pferde gesetzt
und da wusste man noch nix und deswegen
ist es so gekommen wie es gekommen ist
aber es gibt ja einen entscheidenden
moment einen entscheidenden monat das
ist der november wo man wusste dass
bayern tag die deutsche firma zusammen
mit pfizer sehr sehr vorne dabei ist
dass das funktioniert dass es ein
erfolgsmodell ist wo andere nachbestellt
haben also man wusste das ding
funktioniert und die anderen da weiß man
es noch nicht so richtig verstehen sie
das warum da die eu oder am ende dann
eben auch die bundesregierung nicht
gesagt hat so wir müssen das jetzt
stellen damit wir genügend impfstoff für
alle deutschen haben ja ich denke ich
denke es ist ganz offenkundig dass nur
noch viele pferde gesetzt hat aber auf
die auch nicht auf jedes pferd genug
geld und wenn man überlegt wie wenig
eigentlich da ausgegeben worden ist
bisher im vergleich zu dem geld was zur
verfügung gestellt wird um die
wirtschaftlichen folgen der erlaubt es
lockten zu bewältigen
dann ist das denke ich eine schande und
offenbar ein versagen auf der linie der
die dafür verantwortlich sind dass diese
verhandlungen geführt wurden und wie sie
geführt worden und welche mengen
sozusagen dort diskutiert worden
offenbar ein hoch komplexer prozess der
nicht optimal gelaufen ist und ob die eu
jetzt nach steuert oder ob die einzelnen
länder nach steuern das wird sich zeigen
aber es ist kein es ist keine wieder
spannende sagt kraft aus sorgen da es
kraftvollen handelns auf seiten der eu
gewesen
ich glaube es ist eher eine blamage
eine blamage klare worte wenn sie jetzt
schauen was man überhaupt noch machen
kann fakt ist momentan haben wir zu
wenig wir könnten also nur darauf setzen
die produktion anzuschmeißen oder darauf
zu hoffen dass weitere dass es weitere
zulassungen von anderen anbietern gibt
was würden sie der politik jetzt raten
was muss man heute was muss man bei
dieser ministerpräsidentenkonferenz oder
in den nächsten tagen beim thema impfen
unbedingt umsetzen
aus meiner sicht wäre es richtig dass
man vor allen dingen mit den anbietern
deren impfstoffe nicht so kompliziert
logistisch zu kompliziert sind nicht so
tief gekühlt werden müssen noch
verhandlungen aufnimmt über
nachlieferungen mit anderen worten mit
moderner und astrazeneca die ja beide
kurz vor der zulassung stehen oder auch
schon zugelassen sind um substanziell
mehr dosen zu bekommen auch mit mir und
ecke sehr sicherlich sinnvoll nach
verhandlungen zu führen auch wenn ich
gehört habe dass dort die
produktionskapazitäten erst hochgefahren
werden müssen
ich denke das wird die politik ist jetzt
die ist jetzt in der pflicht sozusagen
substanzielle nachverhandlung zu führen
und zu sagen was sie tatsächlich braucht
und was wir brauchen ist eine
ausreichende impfstoffversorgung von
jedem der teilnehmer ich glaube das kann
keine finanziellen gesichtspunkten geben
jetzt ab diese in diesem punkt zu sparen
es zeigt sich dass impfen offenbar die
wirkungsvollste methode ist um mit einer
solchen pandemie fertig zu werden und
sie einzugrenzen und vor allen dingen um
die risikopatienten zu schützen ist dann
diese misswirtschaft jetzt bei dem
corona impfstoff eigentlich nur die
spitze des eisberges in dem ganzen
coruna ja das wär schon hinter uns
gebracht haben
masten die am anfang nicht für alle da
wann wenn man sich nicht ganz sicher ob
die überhaupt was bringen schnelltest
ziemlich eingeführt werden sollten weil
man sich da nicht so ganz sicher war
glauben sie die politik wurde da falsch
beraten oder hat auch einfach falsche
entscheidungen getroffen und war immer
etwas zögerlich ja ich bin ja auch
präsident der europäischen neurologen
verbände
wir sind von der eu nie gefragt worden
experten von unserem verband wurden
nicht einbezogen in die diskussion um
die beschaffung von impfstoffen monologe
bin ich persönlich enttäuscht dass die
angebote die die immunologie machen kann
ja auch mindestens drei ebenen nicht so
wahrgenommen werden wie sei nicht
wahrgenommen werden könnten dass es
erstmal die immunologischen antigen
schnelltests sind die speicher gemacht
werden können
das heißt auch von laien durchgeführt
werden können und die in anderen ländern
außerhalb europas so zum beispiel in
asien mit großem erfolg eingesetzt
werden das zweite sind die
therapeutischen antikörper zum beispiel
die von regeneron die satte ende
november in den usa bereits unter einer
notfallverordnung gegeben werden können
und die sehr sinnvoll sind wenn es darum
geht bei risikopatienten schwere
verläufe ab zumindest die antikörper die
hat trump bekommen hat und jetzt bei den
impfstoffen wieder das gleiche zu wenig
bestellt
zu wenig vorausschauend nicht
nachgesteuert am plan festhalten
ich denke es ist an der zeit dem plan zu
justieren dem plan justieren jetzt ist
ja in diesen momenten die
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz die staaten
soll dort über neue maßnahmen gesprochen
eine maßnahme die wir hier schon viel
gesprochen haben ist die korona leihen
so wie wir sie nennen die jetzt kommen
soll eine möglichkeit ist bei hohen
incidence wert man darf also nur 15
kilometer von seiner meldeadresse weg
ist das etwas wo sie sagen gut das hilft
dann so lange bis wir das mit dem
impfstoff hin bekommen oder sind das
eigentlich maßnahmen die nur davon
ablenken was die eigentlichen probleme
sind wir sind offenbar jetzt immer noch
in der phase und gezwungen mit verboten
zu arbeiten
ich denke es wäre sehr schön wenn auch
angebote gemacht werden
auch über die impfstoffe hinaus zum
beispiel bessere schnelltests und
therapeutische antikörper die werdende
mama theologie übrigens schon seit 20
jahren einsetzen und großem erfolg
vielen patienten geholfen haben also
nicht nur verboten sondern angebote aber
tatsächlich das ist leider so solange
die angebote nicht da sind und auch
nicht greifen sozusagen wird es nötig
sein die die restriktiven lockdown
maßnahmen so effizient zu gestalten dass
tatsächlich die verbreitung auf diese
weise möglichst eingedämmt wird
wir halten ja sozusagen den deckel auf
dem feuer im blick aber das feuer
auszumachen dazu wird das immunologische
maßnahmen benötigen sprich impfstoffe
herr professor radbruch jetzt gehören
sie zu den leopoldina das sind
diejenigen auf die die kanzlerin in
dieser krise so hört man zumindest am
meisten gehört hat wenn sie jetzt das
wirken der kanzlerin auch in der
impfstoff krise bewährten bild hat
gestern einen brief enthüllt aus dem
hervorgeht dass die viel
gesundheitsminister die damals die
impfstoff verhandlungen geführt haben
diese dann an die eu kommission
abgegeben haben offenbar auf druck von
kanzlerin merkel die gesagt hat man muss
das ganze europäische lösen
jetzt steht die kanzlerin genauso wie
die gesundheitsminister und auch ursula
von der leyen massiv unter druck wie
würden sie die kanzlerin in dieser krise
bewerten was hat sie da falsch gemacht
ich finde zunächst mal hat es richtig
gemacht dass es sinnvoll ist die lösung
auf europäischer ebene anzustreben was
vielleicht nicht optimal gelaufen das
ist eben die effizienz dieser
problemlösung auf europäischer ebene zu
gestalten und ich denke wenn europa
zeigen will dass es zusammen mehr
schaffen kann als regierte nation
alleine dann müssen sie auch zeigen dass
die effizient und schnell reagieren
können und ich denke es ist eine große
aufgabe vor uns bevor europa sozusagen
die abläufe so zu optimieren dass man
tatsächlich zusammen schneller ist als
alleine
und nicht langsamer man von denjenigen
die die kanzlerin verteidigen oder die
medien wie auch bild kritisieren dafür
dass wir kritisch darüber berichten was
beim impfstoff passiert ist denjenigen
wird impfstoff nationalismus vorgeworfen
was denken sie darüber
zum vollkommen ab so das argument dass
ich überhaupt nicht verstehe so eine art
totschlag argument ich weiß nicht was
das soll
es geht ja nicht darum dass man in
diesem fall alleine vielleicht sogar
schneller gewesen wäre es geht ja darum
dass man europa schlagkräftig machen
muss und offenbar ist es im augenblick
nicht schlagkräftig jedenfalls was diese
frage betrifft und ich wiederhole dass
das ist eigentlich eine blamage für die
effizienz der abläufe in der eu und das
könnte man sicherlich verbessern und
muss es nur wollen und ich denke da
haben sie ja auch schon den finger drauf
gelegt ohne einen kritischen
journalismus scheint sich da wenig zu
bewegen
sie sprechen es an kritischen
journalismus gleichzeitig fragen wir uns
natürlich was passiert jetzt hier in den
nächsten stunden es gibt bereits
einzelheiten die bekannt sind lockdown
bis zum 31 januar
wir sprechen über das was nele gerade
angesprochen hat die korona leine
wir sprechen darüber dass schulen
eventuell komplett dicht bleiben nur
teilweise geöffnet sind da gibt es
streit aus ihrer sicht als derjenige
auch im teil der leopoldina was ist
jetzt für deutschland der richtige weg
wie kommen wir am schnellsten endlich
aus dieser krise heraus ja so
bedauerlich ich spreche jetzt nur für
mich ich bin zwar mitglied der
leopoldina aber was ich jetzt sage es
nicht abgesprochen innerhalb der
leopoldina
ich würde denken dass es leider zu zeit
nötig ist den lockdown
aufrechtzuerhalten vielleicht sogar noch
zu verschärfen um einfach die instanzen
möglichst durch hygienemaßnahmen
möglichst tief zu drücken
auf der anderen seite sollte man alle
schnellstens und auf der ebene versuchen
die beschaffung von die verfügbarkeit
von impfstoffen
zu maximieren und zumindest die risiko
kooperationen extrem schnell durch zu
kämpfen und nicht sagen wir können
warten bis zum spätsommer und und sehen
und dann haben wir genug impfstoff von
irgendwelchen anbietern die vielleicht
dann noch auf markt kommt und ich denke
diese man musste sozusagen corona in die
zange nehmen
auf der einen seite durch
hygienemaßnahmen und lockdown die
verbreitung möglichst gering halten und
auf der anderen seite extrem schnell
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren